cela donne ça
je me regarde je veux apporter mon
soutien
1 à la question de de lorenzo qui s'est
fâché je regrette qu'il soit parti je
vais rester très calme mais je suis
profondément mal à l'aise voire
scandalisé je pense que d'autres
journalistes d'autres collègues dans ses
deux salles partagent mon sentiment je
pense fondamentalement que tu ne répond
pas à nos questions à des questions qui
sont légitimes c'est inadmissible voilà
je voulais le dire je ne sors pas je ne
sors pas de la salle je me fâche mais
j'ai presque tout d'abord j'apprécie que
tu restes dans la salle c'est déjà un
bon début
deuxième je réitère que les réponses que
nous donnons sont basées sur le droit
essayons d'avoir un week end à bon
mondial je vous vois tout ce lundi